We have a new doc.
You mean from the Trump FEMA and the Trump
CDC?
And it predicts that by June 1st, we may see
3000 corona virus deaths per day.
This is the exact opposite of the prevailing
narrative from the Trump administration.
The prevailing narrative is deaths peaked
in mid-April at about twenty five hundred
a day.
They have been coming down and they will continue
to come down.
So we should start reopening.
That's a big difference than what FEMA and
the CDC say, which is by June 1st, the U.S.
alone will see 200000 new cases a day and
3000 deaths per day.
How could there be such a conflict?
Well, we're going to figure that out.
You all know I have not been playing politics
with Corona virus from day one.
I have no interest in playing politics with
it.
I hope that Donald Trump gets deaths down
to zero like that.
And I have no concerns about the political
implications of that.
I want to see the deaths reduced right away.
I hope Trump is right here and the CDC and
FEMA are wrong.
When we look at the headlines.
So far, cases have been sort of pretty steadily
around 25000 new cases a day since the first
days of April.
We're testing about three times as much now
as we were a month ago.
So if we keep finding 25000 new cases a day,
but we triple testing, that implies that we
are starting to be on the tail end to some
degree when we look at deaths.
We saw what looks like a peak in deaths around
April 20th, around twenty five hundred deaths
a day, although it's been pretty up and down.
One would imagine one would hope that deaths
are going to keep coming down, not go back
up to 3000 a day.
Twenty five days from now, when presented
with these documents from FEMA and the CDC,
the Trump administration so far has simply
said these are real documents, but they have
not been presented to the White House Corona
Virus Task Force.
We've not evaluated them.
We are not in a position to say that CDC and
FEMA are right now what would be a reason
why we would see the numbers seemingly coming
down.
But then go all the way back up later this
month.
Sadly, the answer is something very basic.
The early hot spots seem to be past their
peak.
New York, here in Massachusetts, we had only
1.3 percent case growth yesterday.
New Jersey.
But the places that did not have an early
increase in early breakout outbreak, they
are increasingly on a trajectory to become
hot spots.
That's what viral growth is.
When you look at Florida, for example, bragging
for weeks and weeks that they're they're fine.
They're good to reopen 615 new cases in Florida
on Sunday, more than eight or nine hundred
yesterday in 14 days.
If that trajectory continues, Florida will
be a hub of coronavirus in the United States,
Georgia.
Georgia had three hundred and thirty nine
new cases on Sunday.
On Monday, they had more than double that.
If that trajectory continues, Georgia's in
trouble.
Louisiana, very big increase from Sunday to
Monday.
So the numbers are still small.
You're talking about hundreds of cases a day,
not thousands or tens of thousands.
But look at the percentage increases and extrapolate
out 10, 15 days.
Those will be massive death zones if that
happens.
Now, if we get to 3000 deaths per day around
June 1st, we are going to blow the 100000
person death toll out of the water very, very
quickly.
Just 10 days of 3000 a day is 30k.
If we go from where we are now to 3000 in
the next twenty five days.
That's another 50000 deaths.
So if this estimate is correct, by mid-June
we would be at one hundred and fifty thousand
deaths and we would just be getting started.
I hope that this is not accurate.
That would be a daily 9/11.
What I fear the most is that the Trump administration
knows that they've failed and they are not
going to even address these new concerns from
CDC and FEMA that they're not even going to
try and they're just going to do propaganda
and economic messages from here on out while
shifting the blame for the deaths to governors.
I wish I could say that that wasn't going
to work.
But unfortunately, it may.
They're not beating it.
They're not protecting Americans.
But what they have shown they can do effectively
is shift blame and distract and now say, listen,
we did our part.
We're now doing the economic stuff.
These governors aren't testing enough.
These governors aren't making the right decisions.
These governors haven't secured PPE.
It's on them now.
I hope it doesn't work.
I hope this death toll doesn't even happen.
But this is what CDC and FEMA are now predicting.
Let me know what you think.
Check out the reports.
Check out the papers and let me know on Twitter
at David Pakman.
Also very exciting.
In what is Phase 1 of creating a daily written
digest of The David Pakman Show, we have switched
our newsletter to a service called Sub Stack.
It's totally free.
You can sign up at David Pakman Dot Sub Starcom
or on our Web site.
If you go to David Pakman dot com in the upper
right where it says like, keep in touch.
Get on the newsletter, that also will put
you on this new service.
For now, we are just doing our mailing list
over on substract.
But starting next week and the week after,
it's going to be expanded into like a daily
written digest of the David Pakman shelf.
Completely free sign up.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
the